you
Wow that was uh that was wonderful
George Clooney getting the first Oscar
though that was I was really nice
very proud of him this kind of thing
that could really get a fella laid all
right
how much more can he have before we move
on I want to make a quick program note
about acceptance speeches as always the
producers are incredibly concerned with
them running long so this year they've
come up with a surefire way to
respectfully keep speech length to a
minimum here to demonstrate two-time
Oscar winner Tom Hanks this guy is a lot
heavier than you then you think he's
going to be alright I have to thank
cubby our director cubby you took us on
not just a movie but an adventure to the
streets of Toronto to the Hills of
Jamaica ultimate ultimate this
quintessentially American story that I'd
like to state take the staff back of the
hotel for taking such good care of me
look I'm getting the wrap-up wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute mr.
music I want to say Pauly - Coco Wyatt
was a goldsmith dedicated many Miller
all of these by cracking the choke
so business experts everybody down at
the Playtone galaxy of stars hooch MA
hae-jin to be here with you all is to
walk on the shoulders of giants what
let that be a lesson to everyone ladies
and gentlemen please welcome Ben Stiller
tonight I am presenting the award for
excellence in visual effects or should I
say thanks to the miracle of green
screen technology my disembodied head is
those of you in the audience take a look
at the monitors next to the stage and
you'll see what over a billion viewers
worldwide are marveling at right now
freaky isn't it you might even say that
since the early days of cinema visual
effects have come full circle
this is blowing Spielberg's mind
in a moment
in a moment even my head will disappear
and for the first time in Oscar history
an academy award will be presented I
know what don't worry I'm still here
or I might here and the nominees are The
Chronicles of Narnia The Lion the Witch
and the Wardrobe Dean Wright bill Weston
Hoffer Jim Burnie and Scott forum for
King Kong
Joel Atari Brian van tol Christian
rivers and Richard Taylor
for War of the Worlds Dennis Muren Pablo
Hellman
Randall M Dutra and Daniel sudoc
envelope through the power of movie
magic open yourself
and the Oscar goes to Jolla Terry Brian
van Holt Christian rivers and Richard
Taylor for King Kong this is the first
Academy Award for alcohol and Christian
rivers the third Academy Award for Jolla
Terry and the fifth Academy Award for
Richard Taylor
thank you this is tremendous you know
for those of us who aren't actors it's
really a thrill to be able to create a
character in a performance like Kong but
you know I've got to say we had a really
great actor working with us the whole
time to show us how it's done I've got
to thank Andy Serkis for really giving
us the heart of calm thank you
Peter Jackson Peter just thank you for
continuing to surprise us and delight us
guide us in and for making films that we
all love Fran Walsh Philippa boyens
thank you for giving us this incredible
story to our producers Carol Cunningham
Jann blinken Eileen Moran Annette
Wallace thank you for keeping it all
together to everyone at what a just a
fantastic group of artists we love
working with you thanks for your
dedication and to all of our friends at
Universal thank you for making it all
happen
congratulations to the winners and
congratulations to Ben Stiller and his
amazing green unitard good to have proof
that he's Jewish